how do you create the environment where
people are going to thrive and create
those results that you're talking about
what does it you're asking me the
question what does it mean to be healthy
you're asking me the question what does
it mean to be a great parent like I
don't have five things to be a great
parent right it's a lifestyle and it's
becomes number one with the commitment
that I am responsible for the life of
another human being the growth of
another human being
the closest thing to leadership is
parenting you have to be an infinite
student of parenting you know you want
to be a parent you ask your friends you
ask your own parents you join groups you
read magazines you watch talks whatever
it is you're constantly consuming how to
deal with this constantly changing
challenge of being a parent and its ups
and downs and successes and failures you
know and that's what it is leadership is
the same leaders great leaders are
students of leadership no matter how
achieved they are maybe they're still
learning and it's a lifestyle it's the
lifestyle of what I need to do to look
after people which includes things like
listening learning how to give and
receive feedback learning how to have
effective confrontations how to
discipline when necessary in a way
that's constructive roam the halls get
to know people learning what it means to
ask so many questions how do you ask
questions you know like some people are
naturally good at being curious about
other human beings and some people are
uncomfortable because they're introverts
or whatever socially awkward but we can
learn you know how do you learn to
remembers people's names oh I'm bad at
names no you've just decided you're bad
at names we can learn to be good at
names so that when we walk down the hall
and say hey Tom oh my god he remembers
my name it's a nice feeling it's a
lifestyle it's a lifestyle there are
many many things we have to do and
constantly work on to be a great leader
to create that environment
[Music]